oh my god it's so
bad is it getting worse each time it's
get it's getting worse hey guys we just
hit
1 billion views and to celebrate i sat
down with my longtime editor and partner
dan owens to see how much medical
knowledge he's picked up along the way
we added a spicy twist too you've edited
or at least had your hand netting pretty
much every video on the channel so you
should have
all of the answers
[Music]
chest compressions are two inches deep
120 beats per minute 100. i do it faster
than you
for everyone he gets right i have to
take some wasabi he gets it wrong he has
to have some wasabi and neither of us
are good with spicy
that's gonna it's gonna be really bad
multiple choice nope you have to give
complete answers and i'm the judge
is it safe to crack your own neck
he said so the answer is the answer
is yes it's safe cracking your neck is
probably not a bad thing as long as
you're not doing some crazy techniques
on yourself
would you say that's a fair amount yeah
actually probably the most weird way to
consume it oh dan this is
why i know dude i'm okay for now i don't
think i can do that again
how often do people need to change their
underwear how often do you need to
every day i would do it daily if they're
all about this easy it's going to become
a problem real quick that's what i'm
saying
[Music]
god tim these better get harder is it
true that alkaline water is better than
non-alkaline water
no whether it's alkaline or acidic it
doesn't change the acidity of your blood
that's not how it works i'm going to
give you a question right now spur of
the moment what is your blood ph level
range
range yeah i'll eat this while you guess
it
[Music]
so i can't give you a range give me a
normal blood ph and if it's within the
range
um so the only number in my head is
seven nope
eat it what is it seven point three five
to seven four five
[Applause]
it's that tightly regulated
[Music]
the kick is bad yep
does muscle really weigh more than fat
muscle is more dense than fat
i'm gonna say no well that's like the
typical
uh trick question that people ask what
weighs more a pound of feathers or a
pound of gold
they weigh the same
[Music]
dude you know what's crazy i feel like
i'm going to be able to track this all
the way through my desk
dude i am dragging it it's right here
right here yeah yeah what do you think
about cranberry supplements do they
prevent utis
they don't prevent utis but there's a
caveat that in theory
maybe i shouldn't give you more
information than you asked for the
evidence honestly like i've looked at it
it's fairly weak i can't keep doing it
i'm gonna throw up
[Music]
is it building like is it getting worse
each time it's get it's getting worse
oh dan start getting something wrong
what causes hiccups
is that a trick this is what a trick
it's a straightforward question
the first thing that comes to mind is
like it's not quite known what causes
hiccups actually or am i thinking of
yawns not gonna help you
so i'm gonna say it's not known hiccups
is just a little spasm going
on in your diaphragm which is the muscle
immediately below your lungs
so functionally a hiccup is a spasm the
spasm doesn't cause the hiccups
it does i'll take your word for it you
can take my wasabi for it
you hit my nose this time yeah when it
hits the nose yeah how's it watering now
if i'm trying to get pregnant should i
take prenatal vitamins
i'm gonna say yes should i take prenatal
vitamins if i'm trying to get pregnant
yeah cora you really should
i'm actually having a good time because
i know i didn't i'm not clear like how
much of this
oh my gosh i got some drool
i might do a dan cam on this video i
already wiped it
what are the three muscle types in the
body
skeletal ding ding ding for the first
one i would recognize i would like
if multiple choice would be clutch i'd
get it right away no you can't be here
no no no no no no
i don't know i'm gonna give in the
answer is b smooth muscle cardiac muscle
and skeletal muscle
all right all right i know this one's
going to hurt him so bad it's making me
feel so good it's making me not think
about my own pain
i know that one's going to hurt because
bear looked to me he's like are you sure
[Music]
what brings blood back to the heart i'm
not confident but i think
arteries a carry blood away veins bring
blood back
arteries a away from the heart here we
go
is your stomach bad it's not optimal
yeah what connects
muscle to bone versus bone
to bone this one always trips me up this
connects muscle to bone
i'll say ligaments what connects bones
and muscles together god i'm giving all
of them away
tendons p-whoop man
i'm gonna pre-censor myself pee whoop
man
oh this one's not gonna go well he took
it slow
he took it slow
i love that we both look down while we
do it it'll be better for the edit if
you look up
that's when you see your faces better
for the thumbnails perhaps
i wonder what makes it go in your nose
holy crap
i almost missed the wasabi now you've
eaten so many in a row what is the
actual name for your abs are you looking
for abdominals i'm looking for the
medical term oh like the latin will you
grant me if it's one or two words
two words then i'm not gonna get it can
you take like a full-on guess
no they're called abs because the proper
medical term for them is rectus
abdominis
keep the eye contact that one looked
like it went down i don't think so man
what is the hospital term
for when someone's heart stops and what
should they immediately begin
code blue chest compressions heart
stopping that's the code blue i've
talked about this before
instantly give roles to everybody you do
chest compressions you do this
what was that it was not only a tooth
but because of the panic i flex my
hamstring and i hate myself for it
[Applause]
what does hippa stand for oh
health information protection and
portability act
it's pretty close that's wrong health
insurance
uh protect portability no protection
god you got into my head health
insurance portability and accountability
act
you misspelled it on the first grade
episode oh right there's two a's two a's
not two
god damn dude dude you know any comments
i got off that mike you're an idiot
this looks remarkably like bird you know
what it does
[Applause]
see that part's not so bad it's this
part right here
what you're witnessing here is the
animal beginning to decompose
its own mouth and it starts spreading
into the nasal passageways
and once the nasal passageways are hit
the tears
and he decomposes what's it called when
a lung collapses
pneumothorax oh dad comes in with the
vocabulary
how did you know that i know what it is
i can spell it the whole thing dude i
don't want to do this
[Music]
you got to make it sensual too
it's way better when you try to be
serious about it what is the best
location to give the treatment for an
anaphylactic reaction the thigh
more specific the quad more specific
no get her out epipen into the upper
thigh
quick it's the anterior lateral thigh oh
my god dude can we call that a null
what is the principle called in which
competent patients
have the right to refuse or choose their
own treatment course
are you just talking about the phrase
patient autonomy that's called the
principle of
uh autonomy eat your burden and look in
the camera are you hearing this
uh no i'll listen more actively
[Applause]
[Music]
if you guys knew what i'm thinking about
to try and fight
the pain you wouldn't believe it i'm
thinking about how much my grandparents
suffered in world war ii
that's good dude i'm also gonna think
about your grandparents oh i just had a
mean wasabi burp
oh man in my stomach just compressed
i felt it go and it moved the
the rectus abdominis how should you
sneeze when you're wearing a surgical
mask
i don't know but i'm gonna say step out
of the room
you have to sneeze forward the worst
thing that you can do is turn to the
side and sneeze because then all the
sneeze stuff
all the sneeze stuff all the sneeze
particles comes out onto the patient
[Music]
should i order sushi yeah it comes with
wasabi that's awesome what is the term
for an enlarged tongue ugh that's wrong
macroglossia i believe it's called
[Music]
i survived we survived this and a
billion views
but first of all we have to tell the
audience that i'm injured so they don't
think i'm wearing a weird outfit it is a
grade two hamstring tear slash pull
slash tear
can we put stakes on this we could i
want them well done well done steaks
he's gonna know most of them so it has
to be a punishment can i punch with my
hamstring
it's just not enough of a punishment
maybe we should do something gross like
you and dilshaw did
yeah i don't like that you're not
supposed to like it he has to eat four
kinder eggs yes he bears food i get to
shave your head what if i make you an
ice bath
what video should we recommend they
watch what about how to not get sick
i like that video 10 ways how to not get
sick oldie but a goodie all right well
thanks for watching guys
stay happy and healthy keep watching
click here how to not get sick
pee whoop
you